bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
lo video sono fa vj hem subacchi orti e
sarebbe conosci e tratta bene il tuo
insegnante esatto è quello non è sangue
semplicemente gli ha offerto dai ketchup
e lui ne ha usufruito perché se non
conoscessi games che sarebbero i giochi
dove meghni le persone sono molto
tranquilli e poco violenti credetemi c'è
tipo questa è una pinzatrice nulla premo
calmo zio tutto a posto un po di più che
magari non si è fatto male
ecco stai calmo miglia calmo per
cortesia che misfatti la pinzatrice è
perfetto mi ha finito
che cazzo fai l'ansia nella propria è
perfetta mica un boss
perché questa la domanda che mi pongo
ogni volta che gioca una roba del genere
comunque andiamo avanti aggancio ho
visto le forbici all'ascoltare che non
c'è i capelli dal cin piano per cortesia
cosa li tagli che alla cravatta d'italia
etica cosa gli incassi di un unico mondo
ecco è la cosa più schifosa che abbia
mai visto nella mia vita è come me stai
meglio senza cravatta cioè tifassi
problemi con che siamo a 2 su 10 cos'è
dizionario posso usare di posso parlare
voi si alza le mani che davvero dando al
rocky balboa bravo si ascolta una donna
che botta io darò si vabbè ma stai che
ascoltami quel coso pesa più di te
smettila di maneggiarli mai dato troppi
compiti lurido pranzo corona corona
ti prego sì grazie
ho detto un anno
non sai contava se ne va se devo andare
che belle scarpe ma che ma che cazzo
dice sto tizio ho capito ti spieghi
sempre molto meglio dei miei ex
insegnante di matematica credi a parte
sta roba ragazzi siamo a 3 su 10 è una
sedia pastorali assediate in faccia
credo madonna manca undertaker faceva se
cosa non la guarda alla faccia
terrorizza tissima tra l'altro gli
spiace prossima per magia non sei under
dei cancelli
capitemi ancora un aspetto credo sia
bastato no lui ci salta sopra bene
facendo così mettiamo facciamo la fila
uno a testa saltiamo sopra uno per uno
siamo più di un milione e mezzo secondo
me un po di male glielo facciamo
mettete mi piace se volete saltare anche
voi sopravvivo comunque ragazzi siamo a
4 su 10 una roba lo zaino
io ho fatto non ho ancora capito che
cos'è che ha fatto stormo pilatus però
vabbè andiamo di zaino mio passato
regalo mi cacciano ragazza vabbè allora
6 gen degli che non sono proprio stronzo
fino all'ultimo regalo anche le cose che
gentile sono troppo curioso di capire
che cazzo di un accendino
non un semplice accendino ma un
accendino della madonna perché se no non
ero contento né che faccio regali così
semplici perfetto è finito ok perfetto
minchia un petardo non esploso io ti ho
tantissimo aveva la violenza visto
giocare ancora parte c'è questo questo
il futuro di videogame coach e la presa
della corrente è una roba tipo a vostro
all'ostruzione pensavo gli desse la
corrente non lo strozziamo che è meglio
hai voglia di carlo sica che molto ho
dato a fiat addio
ci puoi fare pino più forte tiro forte
tira forte come quantify seghini bravo
hai fatto prefetto è morto ragazzi sono
madonna che è un killer è una roba che
tanto di cappella l'affare rocky balboa
con dizionario strozzarlo con la
corrente non so quale delle due è ampio
figlio non so se stara al dizionario
questa qual era la più [ __ ] però che chi
sono le api ceo
ci sono delle api the pooh pregio
minchia che botta io l'ho preso come in
testa tra l'altro in via d'una mira che
manco se ci riprova un miliardo di odio
che cazzo fai ballate tony todd addio 6
ballare però non è che cosa fai
lo sta facendo in gergo tutti fa una
pippa zio fatelo dire complimenti mai a
vedere chi casino che hai fatto adesso
che scendi l'orario l'ho già fatto
la pinzatrice dove questo la matita c'è
una partita che cosa che mi chiama la
matita o la spada della madonna fa mica
aprirà che sta facendo bene ma ti alzi
sa mai chi cazzo si no io sta cosa non
l'ho capita maki maki sua ma tranquillo
a posto no a questo mi chiamavo manco
visto ma cos'è una cosa per gonfiarla
bici si accettano scommesse su che cos'è
sta roba ragazzi credo sia la pompa che
spero non capì è una cosa sembra un
porno ma non è verve ad art in anestesia
credo sia anestesia e il suo passato di
preciso se adesso dovete scrivere voi
che non ho capito il cazzotto il
cazzotto finale ci stavano perché non
avevi fatto abbastanza quindi bravo per
una volta non è morto ragazzi perfetto e
non è così tragico sto gioco dai capi
facendo mare i diamanti minecraft che il
così sto gioco praticamente cioè dove
cazzo la tazzina gli occhiali la
caffettiera c'è una caffettiera per te
sono morto sono morto da solo un cazzo
fa mi sono scocciato ginocchia ma no mi
chiami è venuto anche aiutare allora
maestro senato non estro dove ci stava
anche aiutando ma poverino
vabbè
dato ormai eravamo alla 10 finiamo la
pizza c'è anche sopra dopo avergli
versato il te mi raccomando abbiamo
finito ragazzi 10 su 10 è stato
istruttivo credete entrati a immaginare
che sia il vostro proprio questo cioè
una roba pazzesca
tanto lo so che tutti avete un
professore che vi tarta 6 maroni non
prendete esempio da questo gioco
ho finito ragazzi dopo tantissimi
tentativi bellissimo ho ammazzato il mio
prof in 20mila modi diversi adesso mi
scende alla bava dalla bocca perché
posso anche grattarmi dei compiti non me
li corregge nessuno dà morale di tutto
questo ragazzi che la scuola uccide in
senso positivo
io credo che l'unica cosa di illegale
tranne tutte le morti di questo gioco
siano i capelli visto bambino per l'amor
di dio posatelo nonché ragazzi spero che
il video vi sia piaciuto è sfogato
moltissimo anche me anche se ho finito
la scuola ma comunque ho avuto dei prof
molto molto simpatici ma veramente tanto
signor giovanni lei che è stato il mio
prof ma quanti anni la dedico questa
cosa lo scherzo non sto scherzando non
saper niente scherzando ma proprio
bluecar ad ora il wac games comunque mi
fa morì a dar vita a prescindere da
tutto perché sono strani ma proprio
strani dato cosa insegna arabo che non
si capisce un cazzo di quello che scrive
un chiuso l'episodio ragazzi spero che
il video vi sia piaciuto e che consente
ragazze il video è piaciuta stato come
che mi piace anche a pagina di facebook
e come non mi vida trovate la
descrizione terroristi di silente civile
o un prossimo video delle ragazze